en tout cas ces pseudo référendum risque
de changer la donne sur le terrain
puisque le Kremlin prévient il y aura
des conséquences sur la sécurité des
régions annexées la Russie donc qui
prépare les esprits et qui veut
renforcer sa présence militaire c'est
pour cela que la semaine dernière
Poutine a décrété la mobilisation
partielle un appel qui préoccupe nombre
de ces citoyens en une semaine sans
mille russe aurait franchi la frontière
avec le Kazakhstan chiffre donné par les
autorités kazak bonjour Régis vous êtes
notre correspondant dans la région le
président du Kazakhstan promet de
protéger les Russes qui fuient la
mobilisation partielle
oui effectivement c'est ce qu'il a dit
ce matin après avoir dit qu'il n'y avait
pas de crise pas de panique mais que la
situation était difficile et sérieuse en
effet alors il a promis d'apporter des
garanties de la sécurité pour tous ces
russes 98.000 c'est le chiffre qui a été
donné ce matin qui sont arrivés au
Kazakhstan depuis que Monsieur Poutine a
signé le décret pour la mobilisation en
Ukraine mercredi dernier le ministre de
l'intérieur a été un tout petit peu plus
nuancé le ministre de l'Intérieur kazak
puisqu'il a dit que ceux qui dans la
l'extradition sera réclamée par les
autorités russes parce qu'ils avaient
échappé à la mobilisation de façon
illégale serait renvoyé en Russie au
terme d'un processus légal puisque les
deux pays ont des accords pour se faire
mais c'est tout de même quelque chose
qui risque d'inquiéter en partie ces
russes qui entre par cette longue
frontière kazakho russe qui est la
deuxième plus grande longue du monde
7000 km où il y a 50 points de de
passage donc c'est véritablement une des
destinations préférées si j'ose dire des
Russes des hommes russes qui souhaitent
fuir la mobilisation merci
Régis gentil pour ces éléments